hello everybody what's up welcome to
their beautiful Monday I'm here with my
beautiful friend Chris waters oh thanks
Peter at you kind all a man thanks it's
megabit where I play old games with old
friends and today we are playing
jurassic park on the genesis yes i had
almost no experience of this game Chris
waters you love this I have some
powerful nostalgia for this game I was
so psyched for this Jurassic Park was
like one of the first movies I ever
liked one of the first like live-action
movies ever saw in the theater my
parents were like not gonna take movies
so I went a super in the movie the game
was coming out I like saved up my money
i bought it i invited my friends over i
straight like I put the cartridge in the
Genesis and draped a tissue over it to
do like a dramatic reveal for them we're
also integer asking or telling you that
well let's show them what you and your
friend saw we did oh it's a dinosaur I I
didn't see Jurassic Park in theaters my
parents were not having that so I had to
wait for the home release go to his
sleep over to watch it get the VHS in
there and I was like I know why they
didn't want me to see this mild to
serious peril oh the greatest thing
about this game though which was so
surprising to me it was this you could
play as the scientist guy or the friggin
dinosaur what it does i don't animation
yeah so this is the this is the raptor
like voguing for the camera I guess like
what's up so and then grant just looking
terrified yeah this is motion of doing
the twist all right we should we start
with let's start with Grant at least all
right we'll start with Grant but
dinosaurs are on the loose throughout
the island so we're going to make our
way through the jungle to the power
station and the Jurassic Park games that
came out for the genesis in Super
Nintendo we're actually very different
yeah I'm intend to one was like a
top-down sort of not really an RPG but
it has some RPG elements it looks like
the what's that link game the still the
only to the past yeah that one yeah
and the poo that's that's noisy mix all
the time he gets injured you mmm jump
here to avoid falling on spike I'm gonna
give you guys some background on the
Dilophosaurus face about 4 feet tall the
Dilophosaurus is spotted like an owl
yeah with a brilliantly colored crest
that fans out around its neck when
aroused oh my what does it say about
spitting projectile vomit okay seemingly
playful the kangaroo like carnivore
makes a curious hooting sound before its
deadly attack it kills by spitting on
its victims from as far as 20 feet away
with a lethal venom that blinds and
paralyzes its prey so two written entry
to our references in that description
apparently it's owl like yeah that looks
like an owl to you I don't know why was
they've been looking at but it does it
doesn't do the gentle hooting does the
wing brad yeah it's just right in
shrieking come over here so I can yeah
he is just hurling those turds Amanda
they're not turns but they kind of look
like turds yeah their mouth hurts and
then he makes little swish nvidia go to
sleep easy what's up buddy your friendly
right well if that noise oh alright so
this really he's your friend he's not
he's not much I mean he's my friend but
he's also in the way I need to jump
across this gap so you're gonna Durgin
80 so I'm gonna throw a grenade at two
grenades actually cuz he's really big
he's like five what get it I'm out of
here low it would be rude about it
alright some the power station now I'm
gonna meet up with it a good friend of
mine
you seem kind of out of frame over there
I pick up these concussion grenades tell
me this Jeff Goldblum ah no way done
after you could hit him with my deluxe
tranq darts and then he's kind of
twitches there he has like a real bad
seizure and I'm on my way remember what
this batter before but now I have a
battery oh it's probably use it too late
for this I have a charge as a prey so I
can like [ __ ] how to die this horse come
here step into my office Wow deviously
vaporize that I think that's like
they're breathing in kompy' like
vaporization favored copy right now oh
no oh whoa um sorry this is a bad scene
so he's only got one move feel like I
can send him away go away t-rex by
blowing up his face a bunch or maybe
this is the one that I just go by all
right I feel like there is just gonna
start chucking these
oh man this game is filled with a
nerve-shredding action according to the
book are you nervous okay I nerves are
getting a little frayed I gotta [ __ ]
there's a huge are you stranded in t-rex
territory and i miss manuals like real
man i'll see that not like warning this
game will give you a seizure also things
yeah what just happened I don't know
what just happened I just I just boldly
ran all right now there is a really
difficult part which was the rafting so
you like are basically falling down a
labret system of waterfalls and you have
to like turn the raft at the right
points so that you don't fall off the
waterfalls that will kill you but
instead fall down the waterfalls it will
I get you to a lower stage of waterfall
okay so uh so in other words good luck
yeah so like there's a t-rex down there
obviously don't want to go over there
lucky what he stuck it out there yeah
yeah so he's like he's like in a cave
and found some sort of sewer grate it
was like cool so mad so angee look at
him that thing is gonna chomp a crap out
of me watching max will play this the
other day and you reminded me I think
that
yeah like this one you have to reverse
ah because if you go all the way to the
left there your bone I think I posted
jump out here nope I don't think I'm
supposed to do that oh I was there's
another thing there I just was not
supposed to get devoured whole and then
my hat Oh get it it's fine what does
happen huh I fell into the river because
I didn't jump into the boat that was
docked yeah all right here this the wrap
the ruptures backstories a little
different it's the raptor gets out and
then wants to murder everyone right
raptor controls can jump alright jump
super jump can you wrapped you can
pounce pounce is like oh man is there a
chomp of that pounce yeah there is yeah
there's also a penile bill is a kill
that's a straight-up bite like you could
if I didn't knock the copy out I could
eat it for health yeah oh it was really
cool I learnt that I think that there
was a guy over here not for long you can
also eat turkey legs or human leg or
whatever whatever it creature like that
geez casual stance these dudes are just
chillin one of them staring directly
into a wall is staring at the back of
that guy's head is a magic eye man look
you just gotta you gotta focus uh-huh do
not be alarmed by the Raptor oh yeah
what's the deal with rubbers that oh oh
no why did you sprint Chris Raptors
can't swim they can't apparently sprit
to their deaths down around
let's see why not everyone dying in
front of me right do you think I can go
straight down yeah Wow no is that
because this is a Ledge I'm on a very
tiny you sure that's like these like is
that that's water dan yeah I think I can
bounce no Dave you Jurassic Park boom
okay oh dude oh it's eating me damn it
damn it a little hard on for you man
they have it damn it damn it break all
right this copies gonna get it just pure
revenge code oh ok ok not gonna eat them
you should either I thought let's get
real savage Raptors can't open doors no
stymied like there's some trick to
opening and for ya the Raptors gonna
have a door that's the whole thing yeah
all right how do you do it though uh he
whipped with your tail take a live with
your tail tail whip apparently the
rapture oh we can only open kitchen
doors oh of course because foolish yeah
of me because you know the movie right
Oh opt open the door tight thank you
jack it's the same friggin animation as
attack Oh God send this one out with
just the ending we can just watch the
ending just want to straight watch the
ending screwed on ending it yeah view
ending blue sky one well we've seen the
beginning we've seen how perilous it is
in the middle we might as well give you
guys the reward that none of us earned
blue sky out of here did they stuck with
us that's right you guys earned it me
I'm not so I i wish i had meant a little
better for you guys honestly I'm so
sorry they're gonna type in this code
what's got one there you go
yeah credit sassy n-no come up oh but
that's all it was thanks Kaylee for
nothing Oh Jessie Wow freiheit Jesus can
you imagine if you spent all your time
trying to beat the game in this way I
mean there are a lot of games that did
this to you right mm-hmm but made up
give you the credits roll I mean you
probably got like like at the beginning
right we got like a two or three shot
intro like here's the cage here's the
dinosaur face escaping the cage you
probably get at the end something that's
like like a like a raptor here's the
dinosaur there's dinosaur on the boat
and the boats leaving or and I don't
know we're gonna stick with this we're
gonna see what happens out the credits
oh yeah all right yeah it's just one of
those things that's aimed it's like
indistinguishable from a bug so you feel
like you're getting cheated as a player
but you're not actually because that's
the way they designed it I feel cheated
as a player right now you were using
cheats what do you yes oh right I had it
coming to hold add checks out yeah all
right that makes sense all right well
thanks for sticking with us everyone
knows you're a sick part a good game for
the genesis is certainly a slice of
history definitely a game yeah certainly
uh well we'll be back next week with
more megabit not sure what we're gonna
play just yet but I'll let you guys know
on Twitter but meanwhile video game
history month is coming up in May
starting Thursday this week yeah we are
going to have a lot of classic gaming
related content on the site so stay
tuned I'll be putting a lot of stuff out
on Twitter pc Brown Chris waters you are
ctw a TT er s I'll be damned nice work
yeah you and I come back at two o'clock
today playing some four player co-op on
multiple players and if you see multiple
players before you know that we're not
that good at cooperating it's gonna be
fun alright thanks for watching megan
with everyone take care happy Monday